debbie sassen ist acht jahre alt als sie
spurlos verschwindet das mädchen aus
düsseldorf wird am 13 februar 1996 nach
dem schwimmunterricht zum letzten mal
gesehen danach taucht sie nie wieder auf
die polizei die verfolgt natürlich
dutzende spuren aber vergeblich der mir
bleibt verschwunden und zwar bis zum
heutigen tag unser reporter kai feldhaus
der hat jetzt mit der bis mama
gesprochen und sich auf spurensuche nach
dem mädchen begeben
ein fall der deutschland seit 25 jahren
bewegt das verschwinden der fast
achtjährigen deborah sasson
sie wurde mitten aus dem leben gerissen
bis heute ist ihr schicksal ungeklärt wo
ist der b was ist mit ethischen
lebt sie noch
das ist ein ganz liebes mädchen gewesen
der bär hat gerne mit mir gemalt
gebastelt
mit mir
lustige sachen
ich habe sie morgens im bett
verabschiedet
ich hab mir den kopf gestreichelt
und sie geküsst
sie ist nur von der schule
nicht mehr nach hause gekommen
was ist am 13 februar vor 25 jahren
passiert wurde deborah entführt ist sie
opfer eines gewaltverbrechens geworden
mit in düsseldorf
kein mensch
derbys schicksal erschüttert die
menschen über viele jahre
2011 der bayern star und heutige
bundesliga-trainer mark van bommel
kämpft vor millionen zuschauern mit den
tränen und gegen das vergessen wo ist
der bbi saßen die familie funke die
betroffene familie ist vom schicksal
extrem betroffen
erstens verschwindet spurlos mittags in
düsseldorf drei jahre später erhängt
sich ihre 14 jährige schwester und über
all das ist nun die mutter dagmar funke
schwer erkrankt also im grunde an diesem
schicksal zu machen
ein fall der ganz deutschland
erschüttert und viele menschen bis heute
nicht loslässt
die bild berichtet von beginn an über
die ereignisse
reporter kai feldhaus begleitet das
rätsel um der bi fast sein ganzes
berufsleben lang
200 polizisten suchen die kleine deborah
unheimliche entführungsserie zweites
schulmädchen verschwunden deutsche
kinder auf bestellung entführt
düsseldorf wersten dienstag 13 februar
1996 der tag an dem der bi verschwindet
im kohlrausch weg wohnt familie saßen am
frühen morgen weckt mutter dagmar die
fast achtjährige deby ich hab sie
morgens im bett verabschiedet ihr
vater sollte sie also zur schule bringen
ich musste arbeiten
ich hab mir den kopf gestreichelt und
sie geküsst
das war das letzte mal dass dagmar ihre
tochter derby gesehen hat um kurz vor
acht macht sich der bbi alleine auf den
weg zur schule von der wohnung der
familie sind es nur etwa 900 meter bis
zur original grundschule sicher ist sie
ist dort angekommen der bild reporter
vor ort ar spurensuche es ist dienstag
der dreizehnte februar 1996 um 12 uhr
endet der schwimmunterricht der original
grundschule hier im düsseldorfer
stadtteil wersten
der wie saßen das wird eine mitschülerin
später zu protokoll geben soll hier noch
gesehen worden sein und hat den schulhof
dann wahrscheinlich durch diesen
hinterausgang verlassen
was jetzt passiert ist bis heute ein
rätsel
darüber gibt es keine beobachtungen mit
ihrer mutter übt sie den schulweg über
die hier blau markierte kölner
landstraße die sehr beliebt ist die
direkte verbindung über eine grünanlage
hier rot markiert soll sie nicht gehen
da diese nicht gut einzusehen ist doch
welchen weg hat sie gewählt
vor der schule treffen wir den
privatdetektiv dietmar wagner der
ebenfalls von beginn an den fall
begleitet hat
zu hause wird der bbi von ihrer
schwester anita erwartet doch da kommt
sie nicht an
dann kam ich von der kuh aus düsseldorf
zurück
und dann kam anita mission entgegen und
sagte dbs nicht mehr nach hause gekommen
für die familie beginnt ein alptraum wie
kann es sein dass der bbi nicht
zurückkommt einfach verschwindet
es beginnt eine groß angelegte
suchaktion
spürhunde tornados mit wärmebildkameras
die düssel wurde abgepumpt ein kleiner
fluss es wurden keller durchsucht es
wurde später der halterner stausee
abgetaucht niemals in der geschichte der
stadt hat es eine so große suchaktion
gegeben und es gibt hier nicht einen
haushalt ist einen haushalt der nicht
von der polizei befragt worden ist nicht
einmal mindestens zwölfmal wimmelte es
ja vor polizei dass der bbi bleibt
unauffindbar für die familie bricht eine
welt zusammen
was ist passiert der bis mutter macht
sich bis heute vorwürfe
ich hätte nicht arbeiten gehen würden
ich hätte dem iran an der schule abholen
müssen dann wäre das nicht passiert aber
komischerweise in düsseldorf so eine
kleine großstadt hat keiner was gesehen
keiner was gehört die polizei
nichts gar nichts
um ein such plakat zu erstellen wird
derbys komplette kleidung vom tag ihres
verschwindens nachgeschneidert und einer
lebensgroßen puppe angezogen für das
fahndungsfoto montiert die polizei
anschließend ein bild von der bi in die
aufnahme
eine der wenigen spuren die es gab war
die beschreibung eines zu rücken der
einen mann in einem beigen braun auto am
tatort gesehen haben will da hat man
dann einfach dumm bild veröffentlicht
aber auch das hat zu nichts geführt man
hat diesen mann niemals gefunden ein
rückschlag doch dann
49 tage nach der bis verschwinden gibt
es einen neuen hinweis rund 70 kilometer
nördlich von düsseldorf am halterner sie
will jemand etwas beobachtet haben
tornados mit wärmekameras und spürhunde
werden eingesetzt der aufwand ist enorm
ein anonymer brief beschrieb sehr genau
wie die leiche des kindes in einem
blauen müllsack hier
im halterner stausee versenkt worden
sein soll
die polizei schickte boote schickte
taucher
[Musik]
fünf tage lang wurde der sie durch kennt
der brief entpuppte sich als ein
makaberer scherz
ein theologiestudent hatte ihn
geschrieben wollte sich über die ganze
sache lustig machen
er kam vor gericht das gericht kannte
keine gnade er musste die kosten des
einsatzes tragen 26.000 nach
feuerwehreinsatz
leichenspürhunde das über vier fünf
tagen an diesem see
wo ich dann auch noch hin gefahren bin
weil ich dachte sie ist da und wer macht
denn wer macht denn so was ich meine so
was tut man doch
was für eine gefühlsachterbahn zwischen
der hoffnung auf eine spur und der
skrupellosigkeit einer makabren
falschmeldung
neun monate später dann diese
spektakuläre aktion
100.000 fach wird die borers bild auf
milchtüten gedruckt bringt das den
durchbruch doch auch hier kommt nicht
der entscheidende hinweis
bis heute will die polizei wissen wer
kann angaben zu der bis verschwinden
machen bis heute sucht die polizei
derbys rote kleidung und ihre
schultasche seit dem 13 februar 1996
gibt es kein lebenszeichen von ihr auf
dem heimweg von ihrer grundschule im
düsseldorfer stadtteil wersten
verschwindet sie wurde das fast
achtjährige mädchen entführt
ihr verschwinden löst eine der größten
suchaktionen der nachkriegszeit aus
ergebnislos
der fall hypo erschüttert belgien
zusammen mit zwei komplizen soll er
sechs kinder entführt haben vier mädchen
starben er seine lebensgefährtin und ein
handlanger werden verurteilt ist der bbi
in die fänge des belgischen kinderporno
rings gelangt wurden deutsche kinder auf
bestellung entführt
der selbsternannte kinderporno jäger
marcel flöße übermittelt der belgischen
staatsanwaltschaft 10.000 belastende
fotos im fall dutroux weiß er etwas über
den verbleib von der bi
privatdetektiv dietmar wagner nimmt
kontakt mit verlosung auf zusammen mit
der pis mutter dagmar fährt er in die
großstadt antwerpen um der spur
nachzugehen ist der bbi nach belgien
verschleppt worden
der frühesten hat ein ein bild
im internet gefunden ich muss sagen es
sah der demo ähnlich und das ist derby
das ist eher wie das ist die war einfach
eine verzweifelte mutter die sich an
jedem strohhalm klammert mutter dagmar
glaubt fest ihre tochter gefunden zu
haben doch wie so oft in diesem fall
nimmt auch diese spur eine hoffnungslose
wendung
am ende stellte sich allerdings heraus
dass nicht nur diese spur kalt war das
foto war nämlich aus den 70er jahren
also 20 jahre alt viel schlimmer noch
der belgische ermittler was helfer
flüssen war selbst im in der kinderporno
szene aktiv und wurde später wegen
sexuellen missbrauchs von kindern
verurteilt
auch wenn der bbi nicht opfer der
belgischen kinderschänder wurde ist für
mutter dagmar die auseinandersetzung mit
der pis verschwinden ein unendlicher
albtraum
es ist schlimm genug für mich selber ist
es schlimm genug zu wissen dass es so
perversen menschen gibt
die sowas mit kindern machen vielleicht
wurde sie von irgendwelchen
menschenhändlern mitgenommen die organe
brauchen solche gedanken habe ich auch
schon gab doch es sollte noch schlimmer
für die familie kommen fast dreieinhalb
jahre ist der wii inzwischen
verschwunden da erleidet die familie
einen weiteren schlimmen
schicksalsschlag im oktober klopft ein
bekannter an der tür der mutter
ich sagen jetzt haben sie dabei gefunden
das sagte er zu mir
anita ist tot und damit zusammen ihr
klatscht derbys ältere schwester hat
sich das leben genommen mutter und
polizei gehen davon aus dass sie über
den verlust von der bi nie
hinweggekommen ist
dagmars er ist an diesem
schicksalsschlag zerbrochen das hält
keine familie aus der fall derby wird
zum cold case alle ansätze aus ermittelt
[Musik]
wir haben ja wieder weder opfer noch
täter
denn da nicht irgendeiner mal einen ein
herzens einsehen hat und während sich
selber ins reine kommen glaube ich ließ
der fall aufgeklärt wird wir geben nicht
auf
da draußen läuft jemand der ein kind
verschlechtert und wer daran schuld ist
das eine glückliche familie zerbrochen
ist dieser jemand gehört dingfest
gemacht deshalb hören wir nicht auf
daran zu erinnern dass der bbi saßen
verschwunden ist deshalb fragen wir
immer wieder nach wer weiß was mit
diesem kind passiert am dienstag den 13
februar 1996 verschwindet derby in der
nähe der original schule in düsseldorf
wersten wer kann angaben zu ihrem
verschwinden machen der hat derby auf
dem weg zwischen schule und wohnhaus
gesehen wer kann angaben zu der bis
roter kleidung machen auch ihre
schultasche ist bis heute verschwunden
wer hat sie nach dem 13 februar 1996
gesehen
[Musik]
irgendjemand hat irgendwas gesehen oder
gehört
und da bitte ich darum
dann habe ich meine gewissheit und kann
mein kind beerdigen
[Musik]
und tief in ihrem herzen hofft dagmar
funke das derby noch liebt
hinweise an die polizei düsseldorf
damit das schicksal von deborah sasson
geklärt wird
ja und unser reporter kai feldhaus der
hat mir nach den recherchen erzählt dass
das tragische verschwinden von der bi
saßen heute eigentlich so etwas wie der
kälteste aller cold cases in deutschland
ist helfen sie der polizei dass endlich
zu ändern mit ihren hinweisen wenn sie
jetzt doch noch etwas wissen was das
leid der familie endlich beenden kann
dann melden sie sich bei der polizei
düsseldorf unter 0211